Je m'appelle Jean-Marie Taphoureau.
Je suis un habitant du 12ᵉ
arrondissement et engagé
depuis de nombreuses années
au Mouvement Démocrate.
Je suis père de deux enfants
et je suis directeur commercial
dans une entreprise de quincaillerie.
Ma première campagne
en tant que militant,
je l'ai faite en 1981.
Deux Français sur trois,
le juste milieu, 1981, Giscard d'Estaing.
C'est cette famille politique pour laquelle
je me suis engagé fort jeune.
En tant que conseiller national de l'UDF,
j'ai voté pour la création du MoDem
et je suis resté dans cette maison.
C'est pour moi la seule formation politique
qui défend mes idées et je souhaite défendre
les idées du Mouvement Démocrate.
Je suis aussi vice-président
du Mouvement Démocrate de Paris.
On ne peut pas parler de
Paris sans évoquer Marielle de Sarnez.
Marielle de Sarnez avait favorisé
il y a quelques années
la montée d'une nouvelle génération
qui a portée ses fruits.
Maud Gatel qui l'a remplacée
à la tête du Mouvement Démocrate parisien,
a fait strictement la même chose.
C'est une réussite car aujourd'hui,
au sein du Mouvement Démocrate parisien,
nous avons Pierre-Jean, Iris
et le petit Jules Pasquier.
J’espère qu’il ne m’en voudra pas de l’appeler comme ça.
Cette équipe est remarquable
et ça, ça fait plaisir.
Mon engagement, et ce que je fais, c’est aussi
de les accompagner, c’est les encourager
parce que j'ai un engagement historique.
Mais je suis à leurs côtés
parce que c'est eux
qui représentent l'avenir.
J'ai déjà fort à faire
dans mon arrondissement
puisque le 12ᵉ arrondissement
est un arrondissement
de 140000 habitants
avec une organisation très, très lourde
et s'occuper d'un arrondissement
comme celui-ci, ce n'est pas simple.
Nous avons une mairie
qui ne nous est pas spécialement favorable,
mais on arrive à avoir
une respectabilité locale de l'ensemble
des formations politiques.
Il faut être à l'écoute de tous les habitants
et leur dire “Ok, je représente une formation politique,
mais je suis ouvert à tout. Venez discuter avec moi”.
François Bayrou disait
“les étiquettes divisent, les valeurs rassemblent”.
Eh bien ça, c'est un point important,
quand on est présent,
j'ai une petite permanence informelle
que j'organise
tous les jours de marché
dans le 12ᵉ arrondissement.
Tout le monde est le bienvenu
et là, on arrive à rassembler les personnes.